[Music]
Welcome everybody. Uh I want to thank
you for coming to this session today. Um
today I want to talk about AI powered
search and retrieval. Uh and for those
of you who don't know me, my name is
Frank. Uh I am actually a part of the
Voyage AI team and we recently joined
MongoDB. I want to say probably about
three to four months ago. Uh just a
quick introduction to Voyage AI. You
know, we build the most accurate,
cost-effective embedding models and
rerankers for rag and semantic search.
Uh a lot of the applications I think
that we've seen that I've seen in
particular actually go beyond that. So
some folks use it for classification,
others for you know a variety of
different applications as well.
Clustering so on and so forth. Uh Voyage
is available via the Voyage AI API, the
Azure and AWS marketplaces as well. And
now we are a part of MongoDB. So
representing MongoDB. Yeah, thank you.
So we're representing MongoDB here. Uh
and and you know, we're all really
excited to see what the future will
hold. And the reason, you know, I think
in in the past when I would give
presentations like this, I'd actually
talk very very specifically about things
like evaluating evaluation for
embeddings, right? I would talk about
things like um you know, how how do we
rankers uh play a role in your ultimate
retrieval stack? And today I want to go
a little bit higher level. I want to
talk a little bit more about what I like
to call AI search. I know it's a very
very broad term has a lot of different
meanings to different folks but I want
to go I want to start use that as a
starting point and then talk about where
we are today and also to a secondary
extent where we're going as well. So a
quick uh agenda here for the next 10 10
or so minutes. Um the first I want to
give a quick refresher you know a little
bit about uh about embeddings uh about
search and retrieval more broadly in
this day and age. Then I'll talk about
some real world applications. And I
think each of the applications, there's
going to be three. Each of the
applications I'm going to talk about,
I'll probably spend about a minute uh
each there. There's going to be a a
lesson or something to learn or or a key
fact to take away from that application.
And then what's most exciting, I think,
to me and hopefully to the rest of you
as well is what's to come, right?
Where's the future of AI powered search
and retrieval? And and where are we
going from here? So, a quick refresher.
I'm I'm going to blow through these
pretty quickly. AI powered search at
least how I define it and and how I hope
uh this will continue to be defined
moving forward is a search system that
finds related concepts even without
identical wording. I think this is very
important, right? So a lot of folks you
may be familiar with things like TF or
BM25
uh you know AI powered search goes way
beyond that right not only it can
understand keywords it can help you
retrieve based on some of these more
traditional uh information retrieval
algorithms but it can also help you find
related concepts to that point. It also
understands the user's intent. So, for
example, if I am in a, you know, I'm
trying to search for some products to
buy, something to buy, and I say, "My
best friend is sick. Uh, perhaps it can
recommend me some some some, you know,
get well baskets or something like that,
right? It really should be able to
understand what my ultimate meaning is
rather than just saying, hey, okay, my
best friend is sick. Maybe you I'm going
to try to find something that's good for
a best friend." Uh, more generically,
the last thing that I'll mention is that
it can perform some level of reasoning
and some level of instruction following.
And I'll get to that a little bit later
uh in that last section. But to get
right into it, um you know, a really
popular use case of AI powered search
and retrieval is rag. And I'm going to
go through this pretty quickly. The idea
is that without retrieval, you either
get probably some sort of hallucination
or in some cases your LLM is just going
to flat out refuse to respond to you or
it's going to give you a really really
generic answer like the one you see up
here above. Uh but with retrieval with
AI powered search built into it, you get
a much much more grounded response. Uh
again, this use case I think is is
pretty common. These are actually slides
that I uh I took from from Tangu's talk
that's going to be happening at 12:15.
So you guys should definitely go to that
if you're around. Uh and the idea is
that hey, you generate embeddings, use
that for search, and then you give it to
your LLM.
Last thing I want to mention is that
embedding quality here is a very very
core component of AI powered search
retrieval. I think pretty much 95 to 99%
of the systems I've seen out there from
what I get from what I from what I
gather use embeddings in some way shape
or form. The idea is that again you have
embedded you have these this
unstructured data usually it's text PDFs
word documents Google drive files uh
powerpoints etc. uh and you're able to
embed them into a same space such that
when you do a search or you do a you you
try to find a pro you have a prompt you
search for the most relevant documents
you're able to pull that information all
the way up to the top. So I'm going to
go through these pretty quickly. I'll
try to spend about a minute each here.
Um some real world applications of AI
powered search and retrieval. The first
one is chatting with your codebase. And
this is actually if folks have heard of
continue.dev this is actually their
application. and a lot of their code is
open source. You do this is a classic
rag uh plus re-ranking approach. I think
the lesson from this particular
application is that there is no
onesizefitsall
embedding model. There's no
oneizefits-all LLM.
Always do evaluations to see which one
is best for your application. Now, in
this case, continue did theirs and and
they they found that voyage code 3
actually performs the best. Again the
reason is because for a lot of chat with
your codebase applications you want to
have an embedding model and also to a
secondary extent an LLM that is really
really good at understanding well code
documentation and developers so on and
so forth. So this is the first lesson
from the first application. The second
one is that there's you know when it
comes to the second one again it's also
a very domain specific application here
but the second one that I want to
mention is if you see this box here
where there's there there's some
filtering and then there's some other
structured data that's also passed to
this search system
and this is the thing that I want to
highlight for this particular
application is that oftent times and you
know coming from a company that builds
embedding models it's it's hard for me
to say this I think oftent times
embedding embeddings alone are not
Right? If you want to build a really
powerful search and retrieval system,
you need to have a lot of that
structured data that's a part of it. So
to give you an example, beyond just this
particular uh domain, you know, if I
have let's say some legal documents, uh
I embed those legal documents using
Voyage Law 2. Uh but then when I do my
search or if I'm building my agent
perhaps I want to understand I want to
know hey I only want to find documents
that are from a particular state or
maybe I want to find only official legal
documents or I want to find documents
that have a very very particular set of
details inside of them. This is all this
these are all things that can be done uh
at the filtering stage. So this is
typically done directly inside the
vector store. In some cases it's done
after that. Right? So I want to say I
want to be very very clear there is
often times and the second lesson here
is that there's oftentimes other sources
of data other pieces of structured data
that you need to include inside of your
search system as well right uh and and
really you know just go beyond that and
then the last thing you know the last
sort of application these are these are
real world that these are actually built
today the last thing that I want to say
is when it comes to a lot of agentic
retrieval oftent times it's a feedback
loop so your AI search system is no
longer just input output, right?
Sometimes if you get a query, you might
want your LLM to you you'll do some
searches and then you might want your
LLM to expand that query or you might
want your LM to decompose that query.
I'll give you a quick example. Uh if I
ask for something like um you know what
are Twitter's give me Twitter or I guess
X now uh you know give me X's Q4 you
know or 2024 earnings right you could
your LM could decompose that into Q1 Q2
Q3 Q4 earnings and then send that as
four separate queries to these different
vector stores to the different vector
databases so on and so forth on top of
this as well you also see that we're in
the era of agents right 2025 I would say
is the year of the agents maybe even
2026 six as well. And a lot of agents, a
lot of these agentic applications,
they're going to need to be really,
really powerful at conversational data.
So, you really want embeddings. You
really want a search system that's built
around that. Now, there's a lot of
details that's missing in this
particular block diagram, but I think
hopefully that goes to show you uh sort
of the lesson to take away from that.
Okay. So, this is the most so you know,
I just covered three um existing
applications. uh and hopefully these
applications I think they give you a
window into where we are today. um you
know some of the tips some of the tricks
just three of them uh that that's being
used today in these AI search systems
there's many many out there right
there's I think a lot to cover here but
I think what's more exciting to me is is
what's to come in AI powered search and
AI powered retrieval
uh I don't know what happened to my
arrows here I apologize seem to sort of
disappear in the background but the
future is 100% multimodal uh that is the
case for large language models that is
the case for embeddings things for AI
search and retrieval overall that's
going to be the case as well. I think
there's no doubt about that. And when I
say multimodal, I really I don't mean
multimodal in the sense of oh, you know,
I'm I'm I'm an agent that's operating
the real world. I can connect all these
different modalities like sight and and
and and touch and and taste together.
I'm talking more about modal
multimodality just from a pure sort of
like a foundational perspective. The
ability to understand images and text
together or the ability to understand
images, text and audio together. And
it's going to be really important for
search systems. It's going to be really
important for embedding models just as
we have a lot of VLMs out there today.
This particular example is Voyage
multimodal 3. Um again I apologize. I
don't know what happened to the arrows
here. But the idea here is that it can
take text, it can take images or it can
take a combination of text, interle text
and images and really embed all of those
into a single really powerful semantic
space. So it might be a little bit hard
to understand exactly what's going on
here, but uh the query being strong LLMs
and the the nearest uh the nearest sort
of document being uh the claude 3.5 blog
post. So I hope that's a little bit
clear here. I know again um uh I know it
might be a little bit hard to
understand, but this is uh this is one
of the things I want to get to.
The second thing that I also think is
particularly exciting is instruction
tuning. instruction tuning into a second
a secondary extent reasoning as well. So
right now if you look at embeddings and
you look at embedding models they just
take a query or they take a document and
they give you a vector. I think moving
forward we're going to see situations
where in addition to that query or in
addition to that document we want to be
able to steer the vector in a particular
direction or in a particular in a
particular way. Right? So to give an
example perhaps I want to you know in
addition to my query in addition to my
prompt in addition to my search I also
ask I also give it an instruction to say
uh find documents for me that only dive
into detail about this particular aspect
right and that is where I think
instruction tuning uh is really going to
play a huge role moving forward for AI
search retrieval. Uh last thing that I
want to talk about um is uh and this is
sort of a a buzzwordy kind of term out
there is sort of the agent native
database. I think this is this is where
Voyage joining forces with MongoDB is
super exciting for a lot of us. the idea
that today a lot of search and retrieval
there's many many multiple different
components that you have to put
together. And what you see on the left
is actually already a really really
simplified version of that and the
capability to move directly to something
that is just a single piece of
infrastructure that does the embedding
for you. It does the re-ranking for you.
Perhaps it does some of that query
augmentation or query decomposition for
you. Uh all of that inside a single data
platform inside a single database. I
think that is super exciting. So, I
think this is something that you'll see
more and more of this year and also next
year as well and something to look out
for hopefully as well. So, with that
being said, got about three minutes
left. Would love to take any questions
if you have them. Um, but uh I'll also
leave this up for a couple more seconds.
Feel free to uh scan those QR codes,
follow us, and I hope to see you
sometime else at this conference.
[Music]